what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so the flash is it's really the best
thing to come out of DC rebirth to be
honest I mean this I love what Joshua
Williamson is doing with the flashlight
of stories let me the wise because it's
just fun like it's just good
old-fashioned fun enemy and that's what
comics are supposed to be I mean I love
great storytelling I love stories that
are these huge grandiose epics to
stretch on and it takes three years for
the whole story to come to a fruition
I do love those but what I also love are
just these quick little fun stories and
this is a quick little for you seriously
it's not even the biggest thing in the
world it's just a fun that little
get-together with the flash and his
ropes now insurance this was kind of a
necessity but the way the Joshua
Williamson was playing with the room it
was really absolute genius to be quite
frank with DC rebirth it was basically a
jumping-off point for for a lot of new
color book fans people who want to read
Superman Batman you know detective
colleagues Action Comics Wonder Woman
bat woman bad girls who want to stop
work you know a lot of people were
wanting to know where to start out at
you know if you never read Geoff Johns
Green Lantern did he just jump on with
Sam Humphreys Green Lantern and you
learn about the Green Lantern mythos
alongside Jessica Crews and Simon bass
as they're learning about it the flash
had to be treated the exact same way
especially with a TV show being what it
is what the flash expected to be a major
character within the realm of the
Justice League film it makes sense these
things would start to sort of you know
come into a life of their own and give
people a chilling off form but what
Joshua Williamson did is immediately
with the flash Reverb with the with the
flash in DC we burst he put the Rogues
on the backburner and it said he focused
on God speed he focused on small
characters like paper cuts he focused on
the relationship between the new 52
Wally West and Barry Allen and he
focused on how it is they're very copes
with the return of the pre new 52 Wally
West and the fact that nobody knew that
he was gone so it really creates this
cool scenario that's this really really
cool situation here but what the the
return of the Rogues what rogues
reloaded does is it brings the rogues
back to the forefront so the question is
who are the Rogues that's really kind of
the first question we have to ask you
back when geoff johns first took over
the flash series under the 2001 I think
it was what is up happening is geoff
johns where we just kind of looked at
the entirety of the flash landscape
right and said okay well you know one of
the biggest struggles that the flash has
always had is if Mark Waid wasn't
inventing new things like the Speed
Force and the flash mythos was just kind
of starting to drop off because people
were seeing the same old same old they
see the flash go against Captain
they see the flash go against weather
wizard and so on and so forth you know
and individually they would always be
defeated so Jeff Johnson Edison what if
they teamed up what if what are some of
these most notable members of the
Flash's rogues gallery
teamed up and they were basically a team
how are their powers complement one
another
what kind of bickering would go on
between them who would be in charge who
would want to be in charge but couldn't
be in charge I said what we got were the
rose and the Rogues were a beautifully
crafted group that would just they fight
amongst themselves but they would also
end up you know going against going
against the flash and it created some
extremely great storytelling because of
that the Rogues became a hallmark of the
flash mythos a mainstay of the flash
mythos and so I think you'd be
hard-pressed to find anybody who would
be like yeah the road sucks the team
should be broken up I think a lot of
flash fans would say the rogues are
amazing and they have to stay together
so what happened here at least what goes
on with this particular story is we
basically see the rogues returning to
the forefront because keep in mind
during the the story arc lightning
strikes twice the story arc without
God's peace when the experiment took
place and all these people in Central
City basically develop the powers of the
flash the Rogues just kind of bailed out
they were like time to go and they
pretty much split you know and so the
result is that now they're back here
again and the cool thing is the Barry
Allen kids a little bit of a tour he
talks about villains like paper cuts he
always talked about some of these
small-time guys where he's basically
taken out and he's put him in iron
Heights penitentiary and that was the
goal of Joshua win so Joshua Wilson was
like well since the Rogues are out of
the picture let's introduce a few small
people here and there let's introduce
paper cut let's introduce some
small-time guys and if fans like him
will keep them and if they don't it will
just have them sent off to iron Heights
penitentiary and they'll never be seen
or heard from again but Barry Allen also
talked about in the back of his mind he
was always concerned about the Rogues
returned he was always worried about the
fact that the Rogues would come back and
we knew they were mean we as readers
knew it was only a matter of time before
the Rogues made their return and when
they did the question would be how is it
going to happen and what's going to take
place what it does and so very elderly
this kind of goes on this quest you know
this is this journey so to speak to
basically try to uncover information on
where the Rogues might have gone to an
enforcement starts with the most logical
place known associates people who knew
the members of the Rogues whether they
were former teammates whether there are
people that knew the roads before they
became bad guys whatever the case may be
but this ultimately brings Barry Allen
directly into contact with a woman who
was
a very focal figure in the life of like
captain cold and golden glider is still
out of so forth so really you know Lisa
Lisa smart more or less what is up
happening here is very basically told
about when it came to about the idea
when it came to literature smart and
Lisa start that they basically took up
or at least they spend a lot of time
with their grandfather at his business
called polar ice it was the one place
they felt safe but the reason why was
because literally Lisa's parents were
very rude they were very cool you know
released a father should be very cool
and there's some indication here that
maybe there was some measure of abuse
with regards to the kind of things that
they endured but the fact remains that
in polar ice is where they felt the most
safe and so it immediately dawns on
Barry Allen well that's what their were
their base of operations maybe if
Leonard start if Captain Cold is the
leader of the roast that of course he
would have his base of operations in the
one place he feels safe what we're going
to finding out here though is actually a
ruse this is actually a trap and it's
extremely well done the way it's put
together when Barry Allen arrives in the
polar ice when he arrives describe this
building the first thing you notice is
it looks like they just vanished into
thin air like they just immediately took
off the place
still looks like they're they could
easily come back any moment I mean
there's cards on the table there's money
you know they're in the middle of a card
game there's pictures of the flash them
doing their research so on and so forth
but as he's going through and he's
looking at blueprints for a gun that the
Captain Cold have perfected what is up
happening is he basically triggers a
booby trap that was left behind by heat
wave which basically detonates the
entirety of the polar ice building
assuming as though it was intending to
kill Barry Allen in the process now for
pseudo very is able to survive the
explosion just because of the fact that
he can vibrate himself through physical
objects and essentially make himself
intangible so the explosion wouldn't
affect him but what isn't happening is
that as he's leaving one of the
billboards has a camera inside of it and
the camera is being monitored by the
roads and this is where they say this is
our chance to make our move this is our
chance to show the flash what it is that
we're about and that's why I love this
because this story has really has kind
of like an Ocean's eleven feel to it you
know it feels like George Clooney Brad
Pitt you know Julia Roberts Matt Damon
all these guys really kind of banded
together Don Cheadle Bernie Mac so on
and so forth you know it's you know I
guess call Ryder it's a great almost
like a heist story and that's why I like
this because what is up happening is the
plans of the roads as Barry Allen saw
them basically leads him to corto
Maltese and the idea is if the Rogues
are basically going to be stealing a
statue made of pure gold a statue of
mercury that's made from gold and you
and is the most prized piece in corto
Maltese that's what the idea is that if
they were going to commit a crime
they're going to commit a heist it'd be
the perfect heist to commit and so the
result is that once he gets in there at
least almost immediately before he
arrives on the scene of course the road
to break-in and it's so cool to see this
because we are using their powers and
really kind of highlights how the roads
function together mirror master is so on
and so forth and they're all able to
really pose a legitimate challenge to
barry allen when he arrives on the scene
but only insofar that you know it really
kind of takes them by surprise but any
course goes through and presumably
defeats each individual member of the
team but when Leonard smart goes to take
a hostage of course you know very Alan
rescues the girl but then he also
realizes that this this gun that winner
starts holding is in his right hand
Leonard snart is left-handed and this
wasn't Mary Ellen realizes this is not
Leonard smart and what we end up finding
out is that the Rogues were never here
the only person who was here was mirror
master they were basically mirror
duplicates they were mirror copies and
this is when Barry Allen realizes he was
tricked
not only that if Barry Allen was tricky
he has to go against the Geo mirror
copies of himself which is you know he's
of course successfully able to take out
it also begs the question if he was
basically here and the Rogues were not
then where are the Rogues and that's
what it dawns on him the rose hit
central city already that was the goal
the goal was to get the flash out of
Central City so they could basically
make the ultimate heist they can make
the ultimate hit they could take out
central city put out the flash ever
being there and this is so genius this
is so smart because whenever came to the
roads one of the things I was always
kind of funny as a rose would just be
like okay let's get them this time guys
and it would always end up in a fight
the Rogues have to fighting its flash
and their whole goal will be defeated
the question here that we would always
have to pose is but why did the world
just ever give the flash out of Central
City and then robbed the place and
that's exactly what they do they get the
flash out of Central City and they just
like they just robbed the joint I mean
they rotted clean you know and it's so
cool because what they do in the process
or at least what heat wave does in the
process is he basically kind of leaves
his mark he's you know sort of tortious
things and so on and so forth but this
really proves to be the downfall of the
group the reason why I say that is
because again we had talked about how
the Rogues constantly fought amongst
themselves you know how the ropes
constantly fought amongst each other how
they always argue with each other so on
and so forth where we're men
Orion was was a guy who essentially
engineered the deaths of his family by
you know being a pyromaniac ascendant
you're burning the house down
he basically shows back up again to kind
of say you know one final send-off just
say goodbye one last time you know
because the the Rogues intend to leave
centricity behind forever and so the
flash immediately picks up that if they
were either going to be any place that
heatwave would go to it would be to his
old family home but what heatwave does
is he basically uses this as a trick
instead of simply saying goodbye to his
family and kind of having a sentimental
moment he's lured the flash here and his
goal is to take out barry out and that's
why the plans of the Rogues always come
crashing down because someone breaks
formation someone does something they're
not supposed to their own selfish
ambitions get the best of them or maybe
fit selfish ambitions of all the members
of the Rogues get the best of it but
there's always that one that one you
know hits Lydia now one person that
screws it all up and this instance it's
heatwave because of the fact that
heatwave you know allowed his own blind
ambition fizzes ire to kill Barry Al and
get the better of course Barry Allen you
know faces off against them but heatwave
actually seems to take him out and the
indication here is that heatwave
defeated very Allen well of course we
know that would not be the case and if
heatwave did defeat Barry Allen it
certainly wouldn't be by something as
simple as just a flame thrower you know
that managed to subdue him it would have
to be something much more grandiose
because in truth it would just be
disappointing it would be like the death
of Superman where somebody just shot him
with a sniper rifle with a green
kryptonite bullet it'd be the most
lackluster anti-climatic story ever so
again this is kind of Joshua Williamson
messing around whether it's a little bit
saying hey look guys you guys know
what's going on I mean you you guys you
guys know how the game is played you
guys were reading kind of much long
enough you guys know that when a
character is defeated it gets done a
certain way we're not doing it that way
Barry Allen's not defeated so of course
what isn't happening here what we learn
is a Barry Allen basically followed
heatwave back to the location of the
road and captain cold catches on to this
in an incident he catches on to it right
off the bat he's just like - there's no
way you defeated applause I promise you
he way there's no way you successfully
defeated the flash if you did it was a
miracle and God is looking out for you
but of course what most likely happened
is the flash faked his own death and he
follows you here and that's exactly what
happened from here it's just an exercise
in futility I mean the Rogues try to
take out the flash as best they can
there's no contest there's there's no
contest to be had here but
that's not what Joshua Wilson is looking
for one of the things that I think that
Joshua lancet is so good at when it
comes to writing comic books is building
up to something bigger it's building to
a bigger picture they're saying hey guys
here's this event here and here's that
event there and there's that event over
there between these three stories
there's going to be something left
behind and the first story it was
Godspeed and the second story it was you
know potential secondary villains and
this story right here it is the roads
and so what are you basically doing here
is he setting up the idea so the rubs
are going to Maine are very much going
to stay a part of the flash mythos but
what we also enough finding out here is
that where Captain Cold can initially
uses intelligence to sort of break down
and create a gun of his own that could
manipulate the cold but he also says
he's done he was watching Central City
watching the events unfold when you know
the whole situation unfolded with
regards to everybody getting flash
powers and what he did is he duplicated
that experiment but then he weaponized
it and essentially what he's done he's
created the black ice gun and the black
ice gun is designed for no other purpose
than to neutralize the flash and its
entirety then it's actually really cool
to see because what this does is it
basically works in conjunction with his
ice powers he can freeze the flash and
then Barry Allen can't like vibrate
himself out of it you know it's not
really like a kryptonite for Barry Allen
so much is this a way to sort of create
a barrier between Barry and its own
powers kind of reduce his connection to
the Speed Force and that's the coolest
thing about that is because in the end
it's always very Allen and his
connection for the Speed Force and I'm
glad that's not lost on Joshua
Williamson but I mean it's a very easy
weakness to exploit if you know how
Barry's connection to the Speed Force is
a rope all you have to do is get the
right cut at nice you could cut that
rope and Barry Allen is just a man who
can be killed in any conventional way
but if you have someone who can
manipulate that rope if you have
somebody who could sword up mess with a
connection a little bit while it would
necessarily kill Barry out it would
weaken him in an extreme sense now of
course what Barry Allen does you know he
ends up defeating Captain Cold and the
only way they does it's a really sort of
vibrate himself remove himself in a way
where it basically heats up the gun
itself that's always almost like
creating an electric feedback to the gun
especially disabling it for a temporary
amount of time but what it does is it
allows Barry to basically overpower
Captain Cold and this is why sec joshua
williamson is always building up for
something bigger Joshua Williamson is
always building up for something better
now we're the other row
step in and they try to subdue Barry
Allen they try to basically take him out
in the end it doesn't work
what is up happening here is that when
he had essentially defeated Captain cold
but he had also kind of you know
short-circuited these the black ice gun
and it basically was kind of sent out
this shockwave and you know more or less
knocked out the road but the reason why
I say this is a story of where Joshua
Williamson is always building up to
something bigger is because back at iron
Heights penitentiary the roads are
basically thrown into gen-pop
but what also ends up happening is like
paper cuts and a few of these small-time
villains are sort of thrown into this
general communal communal area and when
they get there Captain Cold says Barry
Allen told me that I could be capable of
so much more if I put my engineer you
know my my intelligence to good use also
we're going to do I'm effectively going
to be the kingpin of iron Heights
penitentiary now this begs so serious
questions that's why I love this so much
because now it's not just the rose now
it's not just you know golden glider
it's not just what a wizard it's not
just mere master and heat wave and
trickster and catechol now it's like
eobard thawne now it is Godspeed
now it's some of these most notable
villains of the Flash's landscape
potentially teaming up all fighting him
at the same time and that could create
one hell of a story so I'm really
interested to see what direction things
go in from here but of course I think
the next story going into this
immediately deals with like Daniel west
as far as I'm aware kind of return of
Daniel Wes or at the very least it deals
with Daniel West being transferred to
Belle Reve which indicates that Daniel
West is kind of going to be shanghaied
on to the Suicide Squad which I'd
actually be really had pretty excited to
see I don't know if he ever was part of
the Suicide Squad before but I'd be
curious to see what you know what Daniel
West reverse-flash looks like all the
Suicide Squad I think it'd be kinda cool
but if you guys are new here to come in
to explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob ports
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah oh catch you
all later please
[Music]